tu as dit c'est ça c'est le premier
trimestre demain jura cas ce qu'a dit on
va voir s'il a réussi ou pas c'est parti
là ce soir y'a un truc énorme
c'est vrai j'ai pas trouvé mi live
[Musique]
blonde tu veux m'entraîner avec un
garçon de corpulence moyenne je
t'attends dans ma salle de musculation
il a maigri et non je le castaldi va
faire très très mal cet été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette fois qui se déguise en fait on
dirait soral jamanak faudrait l'habitude
non
ô combien plus bas où il y avait
beaucoup d' aventure magique qui fait
c'est quoi à chalon
[Applaudissements]
je me casse qu'est ce que je t'ai dit le
premier jour ça va cartonner la vérité
ce que je fais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi vous avez équipés
gbagbo
on va démarrer avec vous maxime gainey
alors d'abord l'état alors donc je vous
le dis vous allez me dire bien sûr
en un mot bien sûr et en votre
appréciation auraient tout à l'heure
c'est de dire ses forces ses faiblesses
votre note est votre appréciation
alors point fort bravo benjamin tu as un
pro de la télévision tu t'y connais
effectivement je sais comment ça
fonctionne n'hésite pas à mouiller le
maillot également à faire les happenings
et rendre un peu ridicule mais ça c'est
drôle ça fait partie du personnage était
souvent les amériques alors allez vous
aussi vous voulez descendre après me
hétu est souvent bien informé des
coulisses de la télévision les points
faibles
tu travailles pas cette émission parfois
tu arrives tu débarques et tu découvres
le conducteur il croit ce soir voilà bon
ben ali qui travaillent ont un petit peu
qui avons plusieurs fiches tu es souvent
moqueur avec moi tu dénigres mon travail
moi ça me touche un peu tu tiens à le
dire
et puis que tu arrêtes tes flatulences
intempestives là parce que là ça part à
la catastrophe
[Rires]
alors votre appréciation génération de
l'acquis du savoir et se repose trop sur
celle dont vous lui mettez quoi
avertissements exclusion encouragements
quand on me l'a pas dit ça alors
avertissements avertissement vous lui
mettez un 4 1 4 parce que il a un poil
en moyenne donc y est presque bravo à
léa pool / pas mal géré à dubaï alors
benjamin point fort d'abord tu es
intuitif t instinctif des bons camarades
à un reer extraordinaire complètement
communicatif je trouve que tu es
généreux tu aimes jouer peut-être trop
parce que tu aimes jouer pour perdre
alors que cyril aime jouer pour gagner
et je te l'avais dit ça peut te perdre
points faibles alors évidemment les gas
et c'est fort j'aime bien alors
évidemment ton estomac
c'est là dessus lance comme ça sans
incommodante c'est un vrai problème il
faut vraiment que tu recton transit
qu'elle de la délicatesse d'un catcheur
la dernière faille avait marin'accueil à
côté tout à chaque fois que tu te lever
pour aller fumer on à la pause tu manqué
de la faire valdinguer par terre elle
souffrait donc fait attention vous
souffrez elles sont pleins troisième
problème d'addiction à côté jean michel
maire il est prêt pour la comédie
française
mais à côté de ça je te trouve excellent
pour moi tu exactement comme un bon
livre une couverture top une quatrième
de couverture extraordinaire et à
l'intérieur ça sonne un peu creux
bah vous l'aviez combien j'ai mis très
bonne note 6 si c'était pas mal et
encouragements si caroline ithurbide
alors dans les points forts très bon
camarade effectivement toujours prêt à
déconner effectivement on peut compter
sur toi pourra pour faire le buzz pour
voilà pour [ __ ] un petit peu le bordel
ça te sauve un peu parce que les points
faibles
effectivement c'est une mauvaise foi à
toute épreuve beaucoup d'arguments qui
manquent
quand tu pousse des coups de gueule
quand tu parles d émission et je trouve
que ça donne ça commence à te desservir
énormément commence à avoir le manque
juste juste avant noël
donc peut-être ces voix lasse la petite
trêve avant noël peut-être un peu
fatigué il faut se ressaisir et surtout
chaque côté et un par rapport à l'année
dernière
et si tu t'es intro christophe beaugrand
brillera puisque toi voilà une bonne au
guichet et je mets un avertissement
alors si c'est pas la version cd
encouragements en grand benjamin là là
on a alors attention
mathieu de leurs bas alors mathieu sang
chaud à les cours sur le positif est de
bonne humeur et bien après sur les
points négatifs mais alors coiffé tout
ah oui pour le moment nous sommes sur le
conseil de classe de baccarat castaldi
pour l'instant on a eu les notes de
maxime yannick lui a mis quatre lanotte
devait agir a dit ça y est c'est l'ami 6
et matthieu delormeau on a eu un point
fort le ce qui était et qui était de
bonne humeur
oui c'est déjà pas mal oui bon voila
mais c'est tout après pas les points
faibles
tha comment je pourrais dire comme tout
les bisexuels tu as ce problème est que
nuit d'accord pas notre colis pour
arriver dans l'année vous attendez
qu'ils devraient pas là postale
j'attends plus rien mon fauteuil je
poursuis minutes on a donc pu arriver je
suis derrière lui ça m'a remercié vous
arrêtez d'humour merci je démarre alors
vous avez été très drôle
l'autre jour j'ai regardé l'émission de
télévision vous avez fait une date un
drôle mais non traduit en français un
colis qui va arriver dans l'année je
l'aiderai présentoirs leur et se danse
de son conseil de classe mais parlons
d'abord de maja ma chemise et oui
effectivement et là on dit les choses
mon ami comme tous les bisexuels cas ce
problème tu ne sais pas où te
positionner du coup on perd un peu ta
personnalité dans la culture de chassieu
c'est à locquirec te ment entre kiel et
on sait pas où il est mais autres le
problème tu ne bosses pas tu bosses pas
du tout tu fous rien après contrairement
à jean michel le problème c'est que tu
n'as pas de facilité au départ donc ça
se voit beaucoup plus alors ce qui te
manque pour un terme aux chroniqueurs je
vais être très honnête parce qu'encore
une fois tu es mon ami il te manque lui
même
qu'il aille vers un plus l'année est
encore longue et du bois devoir te
manque l'humour de jean luc il te manque
une présence comme celle de jean mi il
te manque le physique d'un delormeau au
hasard il te manque peut-être le talent
d'un de leurs mots peut-être au hasard
crit manque également aussi je dirais la
verve laberge peut-être d'un de leurs
mots affaire mais deux ont accepté de
toi qu'elle s'est passé n'est pas venu
alors ma conclusion ménagers désolé ça
m'est pas venu ce que je te conseille
peut-être c'est d'aller faire ses armes
dans une émission un petit peu plus
facile parce que t'as pas les vosges
pour toto madmagz ou une émission comme
ça a peut-être est enfui quand tu es
plus fort vim
tu reviens dans l'émission vous
acceptera les bras ouverts voilà ce que
tu as mis en ligne ces gentilles notre
gentil mensuelle à katherine aux jo qui
baguenaudent gentiment cinq matches
d'euros berciaud de gars vous avez fait
vraiment un là-bas je me dis que j'avais
sur le coeur
merci ma caution isabelle alors venant
après lui je vais être moins plus
indulgente a forcément alors tu as une
excellente connaissance du milieu
mettant n'abuse pas en tout cas sur le
faire savoir
tu prends beaucoup de fous rires et fait
d'excellentes vannes mais alors c'est
drôle surtout avec katia ce qui fait que
ça bénéficie plus à jean-luc à
l'ensemble de l'émission c'est chiant
mais moi j'aime bien ta merde tu perds
tu es tu on rouspète mais comme c'est le
moine moi je m'en fiche
honnêtement quand même beaucoup plus que
les deux d'accord très bien les deux et
tu vois trop de choses sous l'angle de
la télé réalité lors surtout me
concernant pas vraiment un gros handicap
qu'est ce que ce sera quand tu auras un
dentier tu comprends pas ce que tu crois
moi j'en ai pas mais tu ne prononce pas
ce qui fait que quand tu dis des choses
intéressantes
jean perche j'en perçois 5% pour ceux
peu normal et c'est ça oui c'est
peut-être ça pour le coup c'est vraiment
l'âge
néanmoins je t'adore à tel point qu'elle
hd étaient comestibles en même temp a
dit non et moi je te mets 8 parce que
franchement tu mens
j'ai roulé à voir pierre ménès son avis
pierre ménès sur benjamin question moi
j'arrive donc j'aime tout le monde
oui méfiez vous pour votre conseil de
classe il se sera des chiens presque
tout le monde
non je j'ai découvert benjamin que
j'apprécie et pas plus que ça avant faut
dire que les émissions qui faisait
m'intéressait pas du tout ça doit jouer
je trouve que tu clash bien j'adore tes
fous rires pour le côté négatif qui
quand même beaucoup de conneries et tu
pètes à ton corps défendant tu pètes
rarement au dessus de ton cul et quand
même pas plus mal et pour comme ça je te
mets un joli 7 avec mes encouragements
ou alors messieurs le maire et celle de
kelly kelly oui alors benjamin
pour ma part je te trouve très cultivé
[Rires]
pour sa part il est vrai qu'alors et moi
j'ai pas qu'il est très clean et le riz
cultivé voyage à bagan vous trouvez pas
de mon histoire d'amour tout d'un gun à
rien toi
attendez vous trouvez pas qu'il y ait de
demain sur la tête de weimar à
l'émission demain alors un quiz
on fera les chroniques et on verra qui
est le plus cultivé raquel garrido
vous allez voir madame aussi très rigolo
on s'amuse bien avec franz marc bien et
c'est vachement agréable je trouve
d'avoir une personne comme toi autour de
cette table
ensuite pour les points négatifs je te
trouve mauvais perdant et même tricheurs
et ça ça me plaît pas du tout même cyril
des fois un petit peu partie à la
tricherie et mars à bas coûts mais ne me
l'ait pas là dedans je vous dise vous
lui mettez combien nous donc au final je
lui mets 7 sur 10 et c'est satisfaisant
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai entendu tellement d'énormités
que je vais zapper les points forts
toute façon j'en avais pas au point fr
est la vérité je voulais dire que ils
portent bien le déguisement et qu' il
est assez sympa et qu'ils arrivent à
l'heure moi s'en fout là les points
forts c'est de l'anecdote il ya
tellement de points faibles mais
benjamin castaldi
vous venez là surtout chez oui pour
toucher votre cachet vous êtes
spectateurs de l'émission vous ne foutez
rien il y à des débats on ne vous entend
pas vous ne travaillez pas ou alors
c'est pire
et ça je vous en veux vous avait prévenu
vous êtes à la solde de vos amis
producteurs
c'est terrible ça c'est dégueulasse
d'accord écrit
et surtout la saison que vous faites là
elle est calamiteuse par rapport à la
précédente mais vous vous effondrez au
fil des émissions c'est vraiment parce
que cyril vous aime ou que vous êtes
dans le besoin qui continue à vous
invitez vous n'avez plus du tout votre
place benjamin alors moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose
si vous aviez fait ici autant de bonnes
interventions que vous avez une d'ivoire
je vous seriez élu meilleur chroniqueur
[Musique]
que je suis honnête alors la note avait
alors comme vous êtes un bon camarade je
vous mets la note de 1 alors bas jamais
atteint gros point fort c'est que quand
tu as une info tu la balance tu la
donnes bombe alors au sermac canada mais
moi c'est un peu le mal logement
le problème a mis tes points faibles
c'est je passe rapidement sur le fait
qu'à partir de 20h15 à peu près tu
sembles dormir c'est alors posons que
j'ai fait il mettre dans les côtés
positifs
il faut bien avouer que je ne sais pas
si c'est parce que tu as mais ce que tu
dis absolument après ans et je n'ai
jamais compris un seul moule ce que tu
es je sais à la scène rock
je sais que la chaîne un moment imaginé
sous-titré de ce que tu disais c'était
trop cher on en direct c'est pareil
c'est ça normal passons rapidement ça
serait trop cruel sur tes problèmes
gastriques mais je les tuerai toi dans
l'histoire de tpm p le chroniqueur vote
on comprend mieux les pecs les
interviews
quel choix binaire vos deux dernières
pentes une excuse on se laisse plus tôt
c'est ballot je suis pas bien
pratiquement pas faire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors les séries je vais dire moi je te
je pense tout bas la note de l'egypte je
vous dis ce que je pense à moi benjamin
castaldi alors benjamin je trouve moi au
contraire je trouve qui fait de très
bonnes émissions jolie quand il fait de
très bonnes émissions elles sont très
très bonnes il a voilà ils ont fait
trois très bonnes sur quatre et y en a
eu
où il est un petit peu en dessous parce
que parfois voilà il pensa voilà la
voiture qui va peut-être acheter les
battre mais néanmoins pour moi il est
indispensable non seulement dans
l'émission mais aussi avant l'émission
parce que à qui je prendrais de losail
aucune bombe n'a nada et plus
franchement cc c'est un de mes meilleurs
potes
vraiment je le dis hors antenne dans ma
chérie je les aime énormément et j'ai
besoin de lui même avant l'émission
parce que je suis content quand il avec
moi on s'éclate on rigole on va nous
charries et je trouve que dans
l'émission il a un truc c'est qu'il
n'est pas langue de bois
mine de rien et benjamins il a encore
une carrière devant lui c'est un très
grand animateur donc mine de rien elle
pourrait être un peu langue de bois et
avoir peur de se mettre mal avec telle
ou telle chaîne ou encore tel ou tel
producteur et il le fait pas il y va à
fond il à fond avec nous franchement
points forts donc c'est ça et points
faibles ou à la benjamin parfois je vous
le dis il a tendance à péter et à
s'endormir pendant l'émission
c'est à dire que quand les deux en même
temps c'est pas facile
[Applaudissements]
ça me connaît depuis quinze ans depuis
des années et c'est quelqu'un quand vous
dites bon camarade c'est vraiment un bon
qu'elle soit il m'est arrivé un truc
dans ma vie c'est là la seule personne
de la télévision qui met appeler et
envoyer un amour ça c'est la première
des choses je trouve que il à défaut de
ses qualités les qualités de ses défauts
je trouve qu'il a aujourd'hui à son âge
une autodérision qui était comme
exemplaire il n'y a pas de filtre entre
ce qu'ils pensent et ce qui dit et c'est
amusant quand il plaide donc pour lui ou
pas mais en tout cas c'est un vrai
personnage de l'édition et c'est un vrai
pilier de l'émission et pas besoin moi
je lui même dans les quarante sept mois
sans voir la note des tweetos dites nous
ce que vous avez pensé de saïx ce que
vous et comment vous trouvez votre début
de saison n'ont écouté il ya des choses
justes qui ont été dites certainement
n'ont aucun intérêt aucun sens que pour
la bad et pour la bonne humeur
j'essaie principe du conseil de classe
c'est vrai qu'on peut passer à côté des
missions d'ashlee très honnêtement
parfois quand on démarre mal et c'est
valable pour moi mais pour l'ensemble
des gens qui sont surpris tôt parfois on
passe à côté des émissions ça c'est vrai
ça ça m'est arrivé pour les flatulences
et plus pour les 4-12 ans lui que
pendant l'émission mais ce que je suis
très fier d'eux de script et hier je
suis très fier parfois par sa via une
prise passe quelque chose sur le plateau
mais quelque chose qui est qui qui
consent quoi j'étais encore là et non et
blague à part non voilà après après tout
ce qui était dit les choses pourraient
des choses moi moi moi vrai
l'articulation c'est s'est pas
complètement juste et surtout le nom de
jean michel dont on ne comprend pas une
seule phrase sûr sûr sûr une mais voilà
donc c'est c'est le jeu mais j'ai hâte
que vous passez sur cette page a mérité
le premier et 2
alors les services agcs alors on connaît
les fournisseurs ils ont rien préparé
alors la note des chroniqueurs s'il vous
plaît 5,3 sur dix ans les truites hausse
la note qui vous ont mis gratuitement
peu plus c'est la loi qui pose le plus
mon badge i et donc moyenne générale
vous avez six vertus
[Musique]
le petit camembert
il définit voilà ce que vous faites en
fait dans l'émission regardez baraka
samedi c'est donc dans l'émission c'est
tous vu les pinceaux de paix c'est donc
un faux 21%
d'après ce que l'on dit il tant en
émission et un concurrence
[Applaudissements]